herzlich willkommen auf der heutigen
rundfahrt das buffet auf dem schiff ist
eröffnet
seither müssen
der rahmen
wie gefällt es ihnen in der schweiz es
ist kühl aber ich mag das
[Musik]
kaum ist der islamische fastenmonat
ramadan vorbei prägen arabische
touristen das straßenbild in interlaken
von jahr zu jahr werden es mehr
diese gäste bringen viel geld
[Musik]
interlaken tourismus betreibt großen
aufwand damit sich touristen aus den
golfstaaten wohlfühlen
sie laden referenten ein um kulturelle
probleme zu vermeiden
um missverständnissen vorzubeugen baby
kommt sie miteinanders folgende sehe
dass ich da sind dass sie sich für das
thema interessieren
halal ist das was muslimen erlaubt ist
das heißt es sind islamische regeln
aufgestellt worden
diese stehen im koran und oft wird der
begriff halal nur mit lebensmittel in
verbindung gebracht aber es ist sehr
viel mehr als heißt was erlaubt ist was
zulässig ist es sind dinge und
handlungen und ist reguliert das
tägliche leben dann verkauf und schulung
letztes jahr habe ich gehört ist jemand
zu mir gekommen hat gesagt wie sollen
wir das machen die kommen immer und und
wollen noch einen discount und
verhandeln aber unsere preise stehen
doch da oben verstehen die das denn
nicht aber das gehört zur natur von uns
wir wollen dass das ist ein sport wenn
sie jemanden kennen ein aber 20 jahre
wer möchte immer noch auch in 20 und 21
jahre mit ihnen handeln
das gehört einfach zum naturell dazu das
ist ein kommunikationsaustausch eine
begrüßung die sie immer und überall
anwenden können nicht nur mit den
arabischen leuten aus dem golf sieger
aus aber ich hatte eine andere sprache
legen würden ist als salami aleikum
haben sie vielleicht schon gehört auch
in filmen
das heißt salaam friede er lag um mit
euch mit dir
salami aleikum
sehr gut
jetzt machen wir zwei gruppen sie
begrüßen sie und sie geben antwort
[Musik]
samstagvormittag in der fußgängerzone
wil st gallen
politiker fast alle mitglieder der svp
sammeln unterschriften für ein
nationales verhüllungsverbot ein verbot
das auch verschleierte touristinnen
betreffen würde
ja
die unterschrift wenn das ganze dann die
sachen für die jungs geschäft zusammen
mit brille zu kommen
wie sie dabei eine wo einfach kampfkraft
und nicht für das team entnahm das ist
einfach so
während überall machen ohne im zug der
herzen oder die täter oder die moschee
diesem morgen im bryant park macht die
wände dass hooligans verhüllt und weiß
was zu ändern
[Applaus]
ich bin muslimin
wie viel das ja maschinenraum luftwaffe
was tradition ist dass meine arbeit
nicht genommen um sich mit verhöhnt wir
waren nicht dass ihre frauen zwingen wie
jetzt sich zu verhüllen
wann sie das waren der reichen nun zu
machen bevor sport ist die hand jetzt
auf rang vor dem landauer militante
konvertiten vor rollen und jetzt ist der
zeitpunkt wo man daraus muss mache da
kann es noch eine tour setzte das ist
entscheiden und eine million der
fachtage waren sie um tradition vor der
freiheit kommen mit seiner worte bis
irgendwann sondern man sagen die fragen
muss jetzt gestellt wird und so
antwortet werden
gleiche partei andere meinung in unter
sehen bei interlaken arbeitet kutcher
ernst voegeli der svp politiker ist
gegen ein verhüllungsverbot
für ihn sind die arabischen gäste ein
segen er will sie auf keinen fall
verärgern
flüge nach europa um nachher nach
hamburg und zürich und animierte die
resultate freut das große special
features vorhanden hieß es die trifft
man auch noch an ort wie so und jetzt
ein arabischer staat und hat wirklich
daran ein friedliches 45 tag da macht
das volk aber als einzelfall und das ist
natürlich ohne wesentliche unterschied
zwischen einer großen gruppe 50 kinos
kommen
st
du kannst du keine zwei kutschen seine
frau erika füge liebt nimmt die
kundinnen und kunden in empfang
80 prozent ihrer gäste die kutsche
fahren kommen aus arabischen ländern
wie diese familie aus riad saudi arabien
sie sind ein glückspilz so schöne
töchter
und tags nicht berühren und japan geht
[Musik]
die schweiz ist super was willst denn
spd und dann eine bedeutung wenn es
eines burka verbot wird durchgesetzt
werden
das natürlich sehr schwierig aber wir
sind halt
das war das großes problem für den
tourismus allgemein aber damit über den
ist aus kriens land als reporter
modernster allein der maschine
bald wird sie wohl normal denkende
blamieren oder aus rheine sitz aus
deutschland russland mit
glaubensfreiheit ich absolut
nachvollziehen dass man
nina junke verunglückt
dass man das nicht verbieten aber dir da
das gerät das sieht richter dass die
richtige berichtet
[Musik]
die abenteuer anbieter in interlaken
stellen sich im sommer ganz auf
arabische kunden ein
[Musik]
wenn der verschluss seine plastik
berührt schließt er auf der anderen
seite funktioniert es genau gleich im
seilpark instruiert ein mitarbeiter die
konten auf arabisch arabische gäste
bleiben nicht nur länger als andere
sie nutzen auch das freizeitangebot sie
schätzen ein wenig nervenkitzel jedoch
ohne zu viel anstrengung
viele arabische touristen wollen nicht
gefilmt werden
auf der flaniermeile von interlaken
spricht der übersetzer passanten an und
sie nicht vor den kopf zu stoßen ihre
zuerst den man so will es die tradition
es ist völlig anders hier als den
arabischen ländern bei uns in saudi
arabien steht der islam über allem
und es wäre undenkbar dass frauen das
gesicht nicht verdecken wie die leute
hier sich kleiden wollen sollen sie
selber entscheiden
uns gefällt es in der schweiz fehlen es
gibt nette menschen und eine
interessante kultur
wir würden sehr gerne wiederkommen aber
wenn ihr gesichtsschleier verbietet
kommen wahrscheinlich viel weniger
touristen
es ist sehr schwierig ich kann es nicht
erlauben dass meine frau und meine
schwester der niqab legen wäre denkbar
dass ihm ein kopftuch tragen
nein das gesicht muss bedeckt sein sie
will nicht
wer mit einer frau reden will muss den
mann um erlaubnis bitten wenn die
schweizer den gesichtsschleier verbieten
wollen ist das ihr recht wenn man kann
die leute darunter nicht erkenne ich
komme wieder
das gesicht ist nicht die hauptsache und
damit kopftuch allein geht es auch nicht
wir sind vom schweizer fernsehen und
wollen mit arabischen touristen reden
haben sie kurze zeit für uns wenn es
verboten wäre das gesicht zu verhüllen
würden sie zurückkommen
ich bin in einer konservativen familie
aufgewachsen und kann mich nicht gegen
sie stellen
mir ist klar das gesicht ist ein
umstrittenes thema
und es gibt leute die es verhüllen und
andere die es nicht tun
verständlich wenn es das noch trotzdem
noch an dieses vorstellen ohne
gesichtsschleier sie stolz beliebige
finden
daniel sulzer der neue tourismusdirektor
von interlaken will dass jeder gast
anziehen kann was er möchte
zu dieser meinung kommt er aus respekt
aber auch aus kommerziellen gründen
winter locker tourismusorganisation geht
schon wieder über 100 klar umrissene
geist fortschritte wie sie sich selten
im ort verhalte mich kulturell religiös
unter anderem bezog neutral oder medizin
vorschreiben wie sie sich in interlaken
ferien machen
wir kennen die diskussion die politische
haltung ist dass es erstens mal nicht so
das problem ist wissen wir oftmals
dargestellt wird und dass wir befürchten
wenn die initiative und die grund über
das engagieren achten rückgang zu
befürchten ist sechs monate zuvor in
interlaken
bei eiskalten temperaturen dreht ein
arabisches filmteam eine mehrteilige
fernseh liebesgeschichte es ist eine
komplizierte beziehungskiste sehr
dramatisch und gefühlvoll erzählt
für die organisation zuständig sind
matthias albrecht von schweiz tourismus
in roth und stefan rieß von interlaken
tourismus
da mag ich eigentlich die moralische
krise was gott denn jetzt interlaken
tourismus bei den drehs natürlich dass
man gute werbefläche behörde das
internet kann man im winter kann zeigt
was eigentlich wichtig dass man die
schöne landschaftsbilder und die
arabische welt getragen
mit unterstützung von schweiz tourismus
sucht interlaken immer neue wege um mehr
arabische gäste anzuziehen
sie offerieren dem filmteam flüge und
übernachtungen und erwarten als
gegenleistung werbung für die schweiz
es ist nicht die erste serie die auf
einladung von schweiz tourismus gedreht
wird
wenn zwei jahre in luzern die
erschwerend dem ramadan jeden tag eine
episode ausgestrahlt wurde und in dem
monat nach dem ramadan hat region luzern
mehr als 100 prozent mehr besucher kam
aus der jazz aus dem romantischen ruhm
es hat auch die aktie von ge unmittelbar
nach der antike die hotels in luzern wo
das drei toten ist und dass texas hat in
die akte impact ja hier gibt es bäume
ihr könnt dort nicht wenden
das ist die autobahn wenn ihr an isa
wald vorbei gefahren seid müsst ihr
weiter bis nach brienz
eine berühmtheit in arabischen ländern
ist die schauspielerin liza gräber es
ist ihre produktionsfirma die die serie
mit ihr selbst in der hauptrolle
produziert
die schweiz bietet die qualität die wir
uns für unsere ferien wünschen auch der
gesundheitssektor ist erstklassig wir
alle kommen gerne
es ist schön und ruhig man hat viel
privatsphäre und auch das wetter ist
wunderbar in der produktion zeigen wir
diese realität
zudem ist einer der hauptdarsteller im
bankenwesen tätig das passt doch
die serie soll während des fastenmonats
ramadan auf vier arabischen
fernsehsendern ausgestrahlt werden
erwartet werden über 100 millionen
zuschauer
solche mehrteiligen liebesgeschichten
sind im arabischen raum ein effizientes
werbemittel da sie vor allem frauen
ansprechen denn laut schweiz tourismus
entscheidend frauen wohin die reise
führt
mahmud moschee die spielt den geliebten
in den drehpausen filmt er weiter für
seine vielen fans im internet
auch ali mohammed in der serie die
konkurrentin von mais akribie filmt
fleißig für ihre snapshot und instagram
follower
[Musik]
es ist so kalt aber weil es hier so
schön aussieht macht mir das nichts aus
ich glaube du kannst dir nicht
vorstellen wie mich diese aussicht
entspannt wir arbeiten zwar genießen es
aber sehr wir laden immer wieder
berühmtheiten in die schweiz sein
du hast davon erzählt du könntest dich
eine gruppe anschließt treffend wie
kontakt gerne kontaktieren werde ich
deswegen denn dann könntest du auf
schweizer reise kommen
zusätzlich zu den berühmten arten
ja du musst nur bilder und filme
veröffentlichen
das mache ich doch bereits und alle
fragen mich wo bist du
schweiz tourismus wird am mail im sommer
nochmals einladen als werbebotschafterin
die ihren fans die schönsten orte
präsentiert
bei familie satt aus bachrain hat die
mutter entschieden dass die reise in die
schweiz führt
ich fühle mich so wohl wenn ich diese
aussicht sehe wie ein gemeldet wir
fragen uns ist das real oder ein gemälde
was ist der unterschied zu eurem land
dort ist das kochend heiß heiß und
staubig die luft verschmutzt
feuchtigkeit staub die sonne brennt und
kann nicht atmen
man hält es nur in klimatisierten räumen
aus zuhause im auto überall braucht es
klimaanlagen es ist 40 bis 45 grad
kochen
was mir hier besonders gut gefällt man
kann überall hin spazieren bei diesem
wetter geht das zuhause ist man nach
einer minute draußen nass geschwitzt am
ersten tag habe ich im hotel nach dem
fitness center gefragt sie erwiderten
die leute hier joggen am morgen draußen
arabische touristen lieben die schweiz
fast eine million übernachtungen haben
sie 2016 gebucht tendenz steigend 430
franken geben arabische touristen pro
tag und kopf aus mehr als alle anderen
[Gelächter]
abdul rachman sadat war banker und ließ
sich mit 55 jahren frühpension ihren
seither geht er mit seiner familie auf
reisen so oft es geht
sie tragen kopftücher
was bedeutet das wir halten uns für
moderne wir können nicht mehr europäer
seien die sind anders
hardliner wir stehen in der mitte als
unsere töchter kinder waren waren sie
kinder
wir ließen sie das leben genießen sie
erwachsen wurden die schule abschlossen
wurde es zeit ein bisschen konservativ
zu werden
vorhin sein wir eine frau mit niqab das
ist sehr schlimm
niemand in unserer familie mag sie das
sind hardliner
sie sind nicht einverstanden mit ihnen
sie stellen uns nicht wir können gut mit
ihnen leben
hier ist es himmlisch
[Musik]
die sommersaison hat begonnen
schauspielerin und social media star
armee neu mit kurzem haar ist auf werbe
reise durch die schweiz mit ihr
unterwegs sind zwei freundinnen amir
abdulla eine schauspielerin aus bachrain
und am nahen mohammad ihre beste
freundin
alle drei haben viele fans im internet
sie besuchen touristenorte begleitet vom
gastgeber matthias albrecht macht eure
kameras bereit
rechts sehen wir das geburtshaus von
ferdy kübler
er war ein berühmter schweizer
velofahrer möchtet ihr ein paar schritte
gehen und fotografieren
[Musik]
ich möchte keine sonne ich sehe sie doch
daheim täglich bis auch hier freilich
aber das ist gut so und muss da vermag
schwarze schokolade
[Musik]
schauen wir was hier in interlaken
gefilmt die leute fragen uns wo sind
diese orte ist es geeignet für familien
flitterwochen freunde
dann konntest du ihnen antworten dass es
sehr schön ist klar ich war zwar
erstmals hier habe aber viele
informationen
er hat sie betrogen
der mann ist der betrüger immer lady
matthias albrecht ist sehr zufrieden
insgesamt 150 millionen zuschauerinnen
und zuschauer haben die soap gesehen wir
sind das original sankt moritz war die
erste winter feriendestinationen der
schweiz sei dann ist sankt moritz
berühmter für wintertourismus als für
den sommer
auch im st moritz setzten sich die
berühmtheiten aus dem arabischen raum in
szene
sind das die ansichten die violetten die
gründen sind erfassung insgesamt 10.000
es waren über 20.000 aber der post
bleibt nur während 24 stunden zum hotel
schrieb ich es ist ein schönes gefühl
wenn sich jemand um dich kümmert den du
nicht einmal kennst das ist ja viel los
so dass medien relativ einfluss sind und
dass sie natürlich persönliche
empfehlungen tipps von celebrity sondern
sehr viel mehr wert wäre
[Musik]
die frauen veröffentlichen ihre filme
und fotos fleißig in den sozialen medien
auf instagram und snapshot bis zu
200.000 mal werden ihre filme angeschaut
ja ja ja
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mohammad ist die beste freundin von
armee zu hause trägt sie kopftuch und
dabei ja ein langes weißes kleid auf
reisen erlaube ihr die familie jedoch
westliche kleidung zu tragen die frauen
sind zwar über 30 jahre alt doch sie
konnten nur an der reise teilnehmen weil
freundinnen dabei sind die ihre eltern
kennen
zuerst sagte meine mutter die nicht
alleine ohne jemanden aus der familie
sie hatte angst ich sagte kein problem
ich bin erwachsen dann sagte sie dino
nun ruft sie an und fragt bist du
glücklich ich bin sehr glücklich ich
möchte meine familie hierher bringen
[Musik]
jetzt mit der selektiven vertriebs wo
man macht die damals glückte meistens
zwei oder drei brit ist mit genannt auf
drei ausnahmen und den han zeit bewusst
wo so schockiert und sind die teile sind
die preise mit behandlung
obwohl am nil berühmt ist und ihr
eigenes geld verdient wohnt sie noch bei
ihren eltern
es wäre undenkbar unverheiratet
auszuziehen
ich möchte jeden moment mit meinen
eltern verbringen so leben wir so sind
wir es gewohnt
ich sehe das bei meinen großeltern und
eltern
auch bei der jüngeren generation meinen
cuisine meinen cousins so wie wir es
gewohnt sind fühlt es sich normal an
von meinen eltern sich weiter zu meinem
ehemann die schauspielerinnen sind
unermüdlich mit dieser reise bringen sie
es auf 2,4 millionen kontakte mit ihren
fans
sie haben die tourismus destination
schweiz erfolgreich beworben
zell am see im österreichischen
bundesland salzburg bei arabischen
touristen eine sehr beliebte
feriendestinationen das könnte sich
ändern
heuer ist die letzte saison in der die
frauen ihr gesicht verschleiern dürfen
ab oktober ist der gesichtsschleier in
ganz österreich verboten
zell am see ist so beliebt dass ihn die
touristen gar einen arabischen namen
gegeben haben und seitdem sie bedeutung
weil in arabische wort salaf dass frieda
und sie ist ein c sie verstehen schon
als ein safe reader oder sie von frieden
sie kommen zum paradies salam sie genau
wie steht im koran
das ist die paradies mit green feldern
weichen und berge wasser und wasserfall
an disney und angenehmes wetter
arabische touristen mögen auch
österreichische trachten ist das für sie
sie können das anprobieren us masters
kleid muss eng anliegen obwohl nicht auf
anhieb verständlich ist warum sie
trachten und kaufen was von ihnen
erzählt wurde
die hat machen dann zu hause mit ihren
freundinnen verwandten die damen was die
treffen sichern und die machen den
richtigen modenschau
also so wie wir wenn wir hier sind zum
beispiel wenn er sowas kaufen oder ein
t-shirt mit seinem setra verkaufen sich
die die ganze montur und machen dann zu
hause eine tolle modenschau jahr für
jahr kommen mehr arabische touristen
nach zell am see rund 400.000
übernachtungen waren es im letzten
tourismusjahr doch diese massen sind
nicht nur ein segen
der ort wurde als araber destination
verschrieen andere gäste blieben aus
vielen einheimischen wird es zu viel
sogar gastronomen beschweren sich
[Musik]
roland theis muss sein schild heute
mitten auf die straße stellen
jemand hat den poller umgefahren meine
these ist natürlich dass es irgendeinen
herrschaften mit mit fahrzeug oder eben
aus dem arabischen raum war einfach
wieder fahren das passiert öfter bei
denen also die machen was kaputt fahren
einfach weiter melden es nicht dass
wurst spätestens wenn er mit tragen
wahrscheinlich zur reparatur ist kommt
man drauf gefahren mit überfüllten
bussen sie drehen im tunnel teilweise um
sie fahren im tunnel 22 sport
nebeneinander gefahren gegen einbahnen
sie also sie halten sich eigentlich fast
nicht an verkehrsregeln das thema
arabische touristen ist in zell am see
ein heikles es war der terror bereichen
thema einfachheit arabische gäste in
diesem bereich mit der bekleidung in den
islam bereich hinein gebracht hat und
das muss man deutlich trennen und das
versuchen wir zu trennen
dabei gäste die mit anderen
kulturbereichen kommen sind ganz einfach
gäste aus anderen bereichen und es so zu
akzeptieren und die anderen bereiche wie
terror in bislang das ist einfach ein
thema der bundespolitik das ist ein
thema bei denen sich sicherheitsbehörden
zu beschäftigen haben aber in der all
den jahren in denen wir gäste hier haben
merkt man einst sie möchten gute zeit
verbringen die können sich hier
verbringen presse gletscher und berg auf
dem kitzsteinhorn erleben arabische
gäste schnee die meisten zum ersten mal
in ihrem leben nur noch diesen sommer
dürfen die frauen einen gesichtsschleier
den niqab tragen
[Musik]
das verhüllungsverbot wurde vor allem
frauen aus saudi arabien treffen
sie sind es die aus religiösen gründen
das gesicht verhüllen
wir fragen ob sie nächstes jahr trotzdem
kommen widerspricht der übersetzer erst
den mann an
ich hoffe dass dieses verbot nicht für
touristen gilt sondern für leute die in
österreich leben
denn touristen wollen einfach kommen und
die ferien genießen
oktober 2017 soll es in österreich
verboten sein das gesicht zu verhüllen
wie finden sie das ich bin verärgert das
ist keine gute sache dass beleidigt uns
das ist unsere kultur
wir haben andere kleider als in europa
wir können uns nicht leicht sein dass
sich seine frau dazu äußert erlaubt er
nicht das ist bei uns nicht üblich
ich will nicht dass im fernsehen kommt
meiner meinung nach gehört es zur
religionsfreiheit einen niqab tragen zu
können und diese freiheit müssen wir
bewahren wie die christen die anderen
religionen ihre freiheit brauchen
das respektieren wir schließlich auch
ich trage den niqab aus persönlicher
überzeugung und ich erlaube nicht dass
jemand daran etwas ändert wir halten uns
immer an die regeln des gastlandes egal
wohin wir reisen
150 euro buße muss bezahlen wer sein
gesicht trotzdem verhüllt durchsetzen
soll dies die polizei es werden auch
keine extra polizisten eingestellt für
die bereiche wir haben bei uns die
bundespolizei die genauso für
schnellfahrer für falsch nicht
angegurtete personen zuständig sind und
mit denen was auffällt dann werden sie
aufklären wie die gesetzeslage ist das
ist auch in der schweiz hinter sich
genau das gleiche und wenn das nicht der
fall ist dann gibt es seit entsprechende
strafen
seit über einem jahr ist es im tessin
verboten sich das gesicht zu verhüllen
seither hat es nur vereinzelt bussen
gegeben
im tessin machen arabische gäste nur
einen kleinen anteil aus
deshalb ist der direktor der lokalen
tourismusorganisationen gelassen
im moment hat die zahlen ermutigend
wir sehen keine großen veränderungen die
touristen passen sich gut an
wir werden in ein paar jahren mehr wird
ante kommunikator wichtig ist dass wir
korrekt kommunizieren
denn frauen höflicher term das sind die
regeln im kanton haben dafür
informationsblätter fabisch meistens
sagt die betroffene sie verstehe und
enthüllt das gesicht man muss einfach
höflich bleiben
kommunikation ist ja und weil das spiel
es gibt hoteliers in interlaken die sich
ein verhüllungsverbot für die ganze
schweiz wünschen christoph emirat
geschäftsführer des zwei sterne hotel
rössli sagt verhüllte araberinnen
verursachen hoteliers ärger und viele
zusätzliche arbeit
sie wisse dass man alles von vier stück
bringt eine szene wenn man sie die
politik also sie fragen ich sage hier
können allen voran zu tun
der täter tötete schließe jede steuer
klar und einfach
haupt stunde lukas nehmen da innen kommt
und so zählt machen
gegenüber den anderen gästen sind eine
klassische frage um frage also hier
sollen wir sie drin sie genau hin
aber mir ja schon hier vielleicht zehn
oder weniger klar
aber generell bin ich bin weniger
geduldig
nach 18 monaten unterschriftensammlung
reichen die politiker 106 1600
unterschriften ein
zum letztmöglichen termin nachmittags um
fünf uhr
[Musik]
[Applaus]
vorsicht und angst
der islam aus möglich sei und die linke
machen sowieso wieder so wie sie es denn
wäre 8 prozent und sony als produzenten
24 kennt überhaupt
der frühere schweizer verschleierung
verbotener warten der sie netzwerk
braucht verwirrter und es muss die ganze
schweiz verboten
diskriminierung von frauen
wohnungspolitik satiriker stellen sich
dazu mit einer volksinitiative für ein
kebab verbot
aber die opel haben
[Musik]
ausprobieren
mir neue volksrecht war es geht wird
probiert störend sind aber einfach
versicherer störe sie haben die
unterschriften gezählt viele
unglückliche grundsätzlich das ist so
und zwar als verschiedene gründe
die verlangen zu verstehen und da geht
es natürlich himmel so ludwig doppelt
unterschrieben
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das menü auf der schiffsrundfahrt kommt
gut an
es ist hanna
ich schätze dieses angebot denn es ist
schwierig in der schweiz essen zu finden
das für uns erlaubt ist umso mehr
genießen mir dass es hier einen halal
abendessen gibt dürfen wir ihrer frau
auch eine frage stellen
[Musik]
sie ist scheu
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
halal bedeutet gemäß islamischem recht
erlaubt nicht erlaubt sind
schweinefleisch oder fleisch von tieren
die andere tiere essen
zudem müssen die tiere nach islamischem
recht geschächtet werden
auch alkohol ist verboten
[Musik]
ich hoffe dass es in der schweiz bald
mehr halal angebote gibt damit wir
wieder kommen kann
denn wir lieben die schweiz
das essen hier ist sehr gut wir danken
gott dafür
irland ist wunderschön und die leute
sind sehr freundlich
die schweiz ist für uns die nummer eins
[Musik]
für kultur al harbi ist erstaunlich dass
der gesichtsschleier in der bevölkerung
so viel auslöst
das über hunderttausend leute sich
dagegen stellen ihn sogar verbieten
möchten sie fragt sich warum
kann es sein dass ich leute vor frauen
wie ihr fürchten
[Musik]
hier sei die araber reisen so gerne
viele von ihnen tragen kann ich möchte
die schweizer deshalb bitten verbietet
den gesichtsschleier nicht ab oktober
gilt ein verbot in österreich
das bedeutet doch dass ab dann noch mehr
touristen aus saudi arabien in die
schweiz kommen davon könnte dir doch
profitieren
[Musik]